nasser et m a dit journaliste
spécialiste de l'iran merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors
quelque chose d'assez notables
aujourd'hui le président iranien dans
croit ni qui a appelé à un changement
dans le mode de gouvernance de son pays
on sait évidemment on l'a rappelé qu'il
ya beaucoup de manifestations après ce
crash de l'avion abattu par erreur
ça veut dire quoi comment vous
l'interprétez on doit lire un début de
remise en cause et deux changements
peut-être si vous permettez je fais
juste mon petit heures remarque j'ai lu
ce matin ses propos certes il a parlé de
la nécessité de respecter le pluralisme
surtout à l'approché des législatives
qui va intervenir d'ici peu mais cela
fait partir du jargon de teulel dite
modérée de régime iranien
mais depuis plus de deux décennies mais
cela reste également sans effet mais il
a surtout parlé de la nécessité de
changer des règlements militaires et
cela dans le contexte actuel le crash de
l'avion au craignent un avant tout par
la défense et rien des gardiens de la
révolution pour que la à l'avenir dit il
cela depuis spa saurait donc les
mécontents du pouvoir iranien voilà pour
en être que déçu il s'agit là d'un
changement cosmétique d'un point de vue
militaire nous dit mais en aucun cas un
changement dans la gouvernance politique
c'est ce qu'on fera en fait le régime
iranien vient de confronter peut-être à
une crise politique majeure sans
précédent ce qui l'a déclenchée ces taux
coûts importants après la mort
l'élimination de racine slimani laumes
militaire le plus important de régie
mais également ce crash de l'avion civil
l'ukrainien ou 176 passagers ont perdu
leur vie cela a créé des émotions
important à travers tout pays
les gens sont descendus dans la rue les
gens qui sont déjà en fait
désillusionnés
à vous et pour crier leur désespoir est
leur absence de toute confiance dans un
système qui a qui traverse une crise de
légitimité ou plutôt dit légitimité
politique aggravée par le contexte
actuel alors c'est vrai qu'on a vu à la
mort du général soliman y avait eu par
les états unis a tué par les états unis
un moment plutôt d'unité nationale en
iran ça veut dire que c'était une toute
petite partie finalement de la
population ou alors une partie d'entre
eux se sont aussi retournés après cette
erreur concernant l'avion comment vous
aimez je pense que j'ai eu l'occasion
justement d'aborder ce sujet d'ici
quelques jours quand cela est arrivé
avec vous sur ce plateau
j'ai douté j'ai dit que finalement ce
sont des moments à sage et le régime
iranien confrontés à des crises
important espérer pourvoir unir sa base
il a mis en mots gains des moniales
logistique assez important pour montrer
qu'on disait le porte parole du
gouvernement iranien
1 et spectacles unité nationale mais
comme nous avons été beaucoup de monde
quand même
il y avait du mal à y avait entre 200 et
250 mille personnes compte je les dis
oui
il faut le capital iranien contenu de 14
voire 15 millions d'habitants vous voyez
le régime iranien essaie de montrer sa
légitimité à travers ce type de
manifestation mais vous savez que dans
le monde moderne pour approuver sa
légitimité
voilà on se réfère plutôt aux urnes on
organise des élections libres réponse à
voir si il y à bala ou légitimité à ce
justement il ya des prochaines élections
légistatives vous l'avez dit le 21
février est ce qu'on doit s'attendre à
une première étape dans le changement ce
qu'on prend le tournant le monde ce
changement en iran
bah vous savez c'est assez tôt de le
dire mais tout indique pour le moment il
y à d'intenses de corée elle au sein de
systèmes entre deux ailes moi j'ai lille
où ce matin comme je disais il ya un
instant des propos de hassen voran y
joue
permettez moi ce pronostic cette
impression qui laissait entendre qu'en
fait que le crash de l'avion et
ukrainiens s'étaient bien vous nous
intentionnel et cela devait était là
prennent août des coûts forcé par les
gardiens de la révolution
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela en fait qu'il
a demandé expressément aux gardiens de
la révolution d'expliquer en détails aux
iraniens comment une chose paraît que
lui-même trouvé incroyable a pu arriver
on va voir
dans les jours à venir d'ailleurs de la
prière de vendredi doit être dirigée par
le guide suprême
chose qu'il ne fait que dans le moment
de crise politique assez important je
pense que le régime iranien est
confronté à des crises important est que
poté d'ici les législatives beaucoup de
choses pour arriver
pour le moment ce qui a pu gagner c'est
avant tout le président américain merci
donald trump en tout cas ne sert et elle
m'a dit merci d'avoir été avec nous en
direct pour avoir apporté votre analyse